[Laughter]  [Music]  i'm honestly not sure if that was a man  either i'm not saying that to be funny i  really don't know and i believe in the  biological differences between the sexes  but i'll admit that sometimes male  feminists can test my faith in that idea  i don't know what to believe in anymore  so so what we see is that to be a  feminist man is to be a neutered man a  controlled man a man shorn of  personality and identity a baby-faced  ball-less simpering eunuch this after  all is the the objective of feminism to  destroy men destroy manhood  male feminists are the utopian ideal of  manhood according to feminism because  they are manhood without manhood they  are the absence of man or they're they  are a void they meant a monstrosity a  disgrace  an embarrassment to their fathers and  their ancestors  other than that you know male feminism  is great  crushed it